Russian missile strikes meanwhile in and
around the Eastern Ukrainian city of
crematork have killed at least eight
people and injured dozens more a rocket
hit a popular dining area in the city
center at least three children are among
the dead emergency crews are assessing
the damage and searching for victims in
the rubble a second missile struck a
village on the city's outskirts injuring
at least five people there
I ran here after the explosion because I
rented a cafe here everything has been
blown out there's nothing no windows no
doors all I see is destruction fear and
horror this is the 21st century
all the destruction it's shocking to see
in real life when you see it in photos
it's different what you see on TV
doesn't even begin to show what you see
in real life let's bring in Assad bag
now who's live for us in the capital
cave outside what more have you learned
about this most recent attack and those
impacted
foreign
just heard some latest reports from the
regional prosecutor that one more person
has been found a corpse has been found
in that trouble so that takes the death
toll to nine now we understand that a
one-year-old child was also injured in
that but also three children now the
prosecutor's office has said that they
it was a skander missile which is a
short-range ballistic missile we believe
that hit that Cafe now when you go to
chromatos it's it used to have a
population of 150 000 now since the
start of the war that has reduced it's
very quiet and you do see a lot of
military but this was one of the few
restaurants that were still open and the
attack came around eight to nine o'clock
yesterday evening at a time where people
would have been having their dinner and
it's one of the few like I said one of
the few restaurants that still open is
unlike Keith where many restaurants and
shopping centers are open chromatos
isn't like that so this is why it's had
such an impact but also it's not far
from the front lines in the east of the
country about 25 kilometers from the
front lines and it is a major city to
the west of the front lines in Donetsk
and a major city that the Russia will
want to Target in any advance and try to
take over the region but this isn't the
first time this criminals has been
targeted it was targeted back in April
uh last year the city's train station
was 60 around 63 people died but as I
said they're still cleaning up the
rubland one more body has been found all
right thanks so much for bringing us up
to speed Assad baig live in quiche